do you believe that mr depp
is still a shroud of mystery not visible
to the public
no
and when did that change
i don't know exactly when
would you say it was cumulative over the
period of time as a result of all of the
litigation and the publicity ensuing
probably
is there any one specific litigation
that you believe most significantly
impacted
on mr depp's personal reputation no
longer being a shroud of mystery and not
visible to the public
my opinion is that amber's accusations
would have had the most dramatic impact
on
[Music]
his off-screen reputation
i'm not talking about
any
one specific
accusation
when you say amber's accusations
what do you mean by that
i i mean the things that
she's accused johnny of doing
both
in
[Music]
that have been made public
would
amber have been filing the divorce
action
and obtaining a domestic violence
restraining order have had a dramatic
impact
on mr deb's off-screen reputation
i think the only way i can answer that
is
by saying
i don't think
filing for divorce
would have any impact whatsoever
and
i'm actually not familiar with the
lawsuit to get the restraining order so
i don't know
exactly what's in there
but
if
that was based on
claims of or accusations of
abuse
then that
in my opinion
would have a negative impact on johnny's
offscreen reputation
are you aware of
any role or business opportunities that
mr depp lost as a result of
the op-ed by amble third in the
washington post
are you aware of any roles or
business opportunities that mr depp lost
as a result of the waldman tweets in may
2020 relating to amber's outfit
now
is there any other
role
or business opportunity
that mr depp
has lost
since
you started representing him in october
2016.
i would say yes
what
the pirates the the next pirates movie
do you remember which one that was
six seven i'm not sure what the number
is what is your understanding of why mr
depp's
lost private sex
my opinion
is that it was related to the
accusations
that amber has made
what is your opinion based on
conversations with studios and other
executives both
internal and external
what do you recall jerry bruckheimer
telling you
i i don't recall the specific
conversations
but
the
nature of it was that the studio
was
having difficulty employing him
and did mr brock climber
tell you why the studio was having
difficulty employing mr duff
no not specifically but it was
understood
did you ask
i didn't need to
why did you think you didn't need to
because
everyone was aware of what was garnering
the
attention of the studios and determining
whether or not he could be employed
you